gpt4 is coming out this week this week
and also Samsung is in trouble because
they fake the moon my name is Yannick
and this is ml news
[Music]
ppt4 is apparently coming out this week
hi I'm Yannick you may recognize me from
the video you're watching this week was
certainly one of the biggest weeks in AI
Google announced an API to their huge
Palm models and also an integration into
their workspace features which means
docs presentations spreadsheets and so
on AI augmented Microsoft did the same
announcing co-pilot for office which
means that soon you'll be able to you
know write a word document or make a
PowerPoint presentation and be supported
by generative AI anthropic announced
their Claude model which is a chatbot
that they have trained and is said to be
very good on the same time llama has
been made to run on on like old
smartphones
um maybe someone's toaster so this is
these giant language models people are
taking them and they are doing
incredible things with it and of course
on top of it all GPT 4 was announced so
the new model by openai it's apparently
a lot better than the old GPT 3.5 models
or chat GPT models and it's a giant
announcement and and this guy right here
um he's recording this on Monday morning
and he has no clue of that in fact he's
going to claim that he believes that
gpt4 will not be announced this week and
he'll be very very smug about it so I
thought I won't spare you this and I'll
um let you have this I cut it together a
little bit
um but you know I believe in making
falsifiable predictions and I was
falsified in this case we can dive into
all the big news uh next week as I said
all of this is before that so my main
news here is that Samsung fakes the moon
not the moon landing the moon which is
also pretty cool but enjoy the current
Buzz of AI it's a fantastic world I'm
sure it's gonna stay exciting remain
exciting and continue even more glorious
that's it from me enjoy the video I'll
see you this article in highs online
here this is the original article I
could find it's in German but I'll do my
best to translate they say gpt4 will
appear next week and that was last week
so this week the CTO of Microsoft
Germany so a high-ranking Microsoft
Germany employees said that gpt4 was
immediate before release saying we will
next week present gpt4 there we have
multi-modal models they offer very
different possibilities for example
video this is a strong statement
obviously in the whole whole media
landscape is going absolutely crazy here
but you know if you happen to think wait
a minute wait a minute it's kind of
weird that like some German employees of
Microsoft are making the announcement
for gpt4 you know one of the most highly
anticipated releases in the AI world for
the last two years or so it's kind of
weird it's kind of weird it's not open
AI you know for every other one of their
product they release like a big blog
post you know shiny examples and whatnot
and that's their announcement of the
thing and they go all out no it's like
Microsoft officials not open air
Microsoft officials in Germany not even
in English-speaking event if you're a
bit skeptical so am I my guess my guess
is that it's very probable this person
misspoke this person meant something
else not gpt4 in fact we're gonna see a
later in this episode visual chat GPT
which can interact with text and with
images and so on and maybe video is
going to be added to that a little bit
too no offense to like this person I'm
sure they're doing a great job but it'd
be super weird if they were the one to
announce this now there is a bit of a
smaller chance a highest chance misspoke
smaller chance that this person person
kind of blob something out they
shouldn't and there is a teeny tiny
chance that this was the actual
announcement so my prediction is there
will be no GPT for this week
[Music]
Gans are making a return generative
adversarial networks were the absolute
hype when I started my PhD around 2015
2016 and they're making a comeback so
Gans for a long time have been the sort
of state of the art in image generation
they were fast they were super crisp
compared to variational autoencoders
which were the alternative back then
Gans were the thing and now recently
they've been replaced by diffusion
models which tended to have better
quality images and also be steerable via
something like text now Gans are making
a combat so this here is giga Gan the
paper is called scaling up Gans for text
to image synthesis and the pictures here
just look beautiful and you can see
they're all created from images so this
augments Gans in a way so you can also
input a piece of text and then have
something be produced and the cool thing
is given that their Gans you retain all
these abilities like latent space
interpolations Also what this this paper
does is they do a stylegan approach
which means that at different
resolutions of the image so they have
like core screen generation on top of
that they have more finer grain
generation and so on if you know for
example a LaPlace pyramid is very
similar concept they can apply different
conditioning information on the
different levels as I said like style
gun oh yeah they also pair this with an
up sampler so that's this this is what
the up sampler does this is what the Gan
would produce and then after the up
sampler it looks absolutely beautiful as
I said the architecture is right here
generator architecture you can see there
is a lot of tricks in here so it starts
with a pre-trained text encoder they
take that from clip because clip is
already trained to pair text and images
on top of that they learn a small
encoder and then they use that both as
conditioning information but also as
kind of input it gets very complicated
in the exact details I don't want to go
in here but as I said they can do at
different scales of resolution and they
have this interpolation so for example
they can say we generate a teddy bear on
a tabletop and then at the finer grain
resolution they can say something like
ah we want it to be in crochet we want
it to be made of fur we want it to be
made of denim and then you can see the
teddy bear at the finer grain scale gets
that conditioning information so you'll
get a teddy bear made out of fur for
example very nice very controllable and
very cool so there are a lot of
possibilities that open up here with
models like this and it's cool to see
that Gans are making a comeback because
in a diffusion model I really need to do
this step-by-step diffusion there are
some tricks to speed it up but again can
just Chuck a bomb produce that image the
bitter lesson again is that apparently
scale is just the thing you need like
you need scale you need a lot of
parameters and then pretty much any
approach can be made to work but the
cool thing is that I like when new
paradigms come around even though Gans
have been around since 2014 and some
people say since the 90s I welcome this
development and is going to open up to a
cool new research area and I hope with
super fast image generation given by
Gans we have very new possibilities to
create experiences to create
applications to push the state of the
art so very cool
I just thought I'd throw this in here
choppedai.com you can make a recipe so
you say okay I have some chicken it okay
I have some chicken and I have some
butter and I have some uh parsley I
don't know how to spell that and I have
some some rusty nails I also have some
benzodia
diazepam
and yeah and I have nothing of course
okay so I click here and let's see what
it gives so apparently this is supposed
to give me a recipe uh let's see whether
it works it's an age-old idea sorry I
cannot provide the recipe that includes
Rusty Nails and better as they're not
edible ingredient that is not true okay
I wreck though okay in any case it's
something something neat to play around
very cool thank you
here is a Reddit thread and it carries a
pretty serious accusation I want to say
it's called Samsung space Zoom Moon
shots are fake and here is the proof so
this person has picked up on a debate
that has actually been going on for a
while so previously people have already
erased this issue a little bit but what
were dismissed largely and now this
person seems to gather some steam gather
some support so what is this about this
company called Samsung they make phones
and specifically they make phones and
they claim the phones have very good
cameras and they also put some AI models
into the phones or into the cameras I'm
not sure where the model sit probably in
the phones they try to make your
pictures that you take with the camera
as nice as possible now a lot of
companies I I guess pretty much every
single smartphone nowadays does this but
Samsung seems to have a specific
affection for sort of pictures of the
sky or pictures of the night sky so what
they do is they try to enhance this a
lot what this person now has done is
they've taken this particular picture
right here this is a picture of the Moon
not taken with the smartphone this is I
guess a NASA picture of the Moon they
have blurred it so they've applied a
layer of gaussian blur to it so this is
now the picture it's very blurred you
know this is this is it this is the
upscaled variant of it and then they've
taken their phone and they have taken a
picture of their screen showing the
Blurred image okay so instead of
pointing at the sky they actually point
it at the they actually pointed at the
screen as far as I can understand and
this is the picture that comes out of
that now as you may see it's quite
different so in effect there is
information here that is not in the
original so there is no way the camera
can actually gather this image
information people previously already
said that the moon shots look fake or
they're replaced by some texture and
people could always say well no you know
by moving around a little bit the camera
can gather and then do a super
resolution from the different images one
after another in this case it's very
clear the information to produce this
picture here is just not in the original
like the information is just not there
it's been destroyed and this person now
claims this is proof that Samsung
essentially applies a texture so they
they detect the moon and then they just
went Ah that's the moon bang slap okay
they made a different experiment as well
where they just took half of that
picture here are the different results
so when it's just half of the picture
the camera doesn't manage to add all
that detail but when it's the full
picture it does manage to add all that
detail so that lends a lot of
credibility to the fact that they are in
fact detecting the moon and then
replacing it with a texture however I
don't think that's what's going on right
here I think what Samsung has done is
they've actually trained a super
resolution model like we've seen before
here so this is a a super resolution
model it's a model that you give a
blurry image and it gives you a high
resolution image now obviously this
model is going to have to invent
information that isn't there and this is
usually works quite well because deep
learning models generalize so you train
it on a whole bunch of blurry images or
of images of high resolution which you
blur and you train the model to reverse
that that's a super resolution that's an
up sampling model so they have to invent
all of these details and they do that by
learning from data now in case of the
Moon there is a thing called a tidal
lock which means that the moon and the
Earth's water they interact and the
result of it is that we always see the
same side of the moon there's literally
there's not a dark side of the moon per
se like it's not always the same the
dark side switches but the side we see
is always the same and therefore if
Samsung trains a super resolution model
of pictures of the Moon which are
obviously all take taken from Earth
right it will always look the same like
the only difference is that it might be
slightly rotated depending on whether
you're in Australia or not in Australia
and therefore rather than the super
resolution model learning to generalize
and upsample kinds of things just learn
to apply the same texture of the Moon
over and over again so it's not
essentially an algorithm that just
applies the texture my guess is that's
just the super resolution model just
ignores all the input as long as it's
kind of round and kind of bubbly it just
replaces that with its learned texture
of the Moon which is pretty funny it
would be really interesting to get your
hands on this model and see like that
most of the input weights are zeros like
it completely ignores it's just a circle
detector but in any case I think it's
maybe a lesson of what happens if you
just follow AI sort of application like
we throw AI at everything and literally
if we had just built the actual Moon
detector and replaced it with with a
texture we could have gotten the same
result in any case maybe there's some
more developments on this user u i break
photos very nice investigation very
clever experiments to really figure out
what's going on here if you're
interested I'll leave a link in the
description hey let me quickly jump in
and just talk to you about the fact that
weights and biases has not only been
really kind to my channel in the past
but they've also sponsored an entire
team account to the open Assistant
effort open assistant is not me it's
actually a big part like a big Community
lots of volunteers doing work I'm the
person here on camera bringing in the
traffic weights and biases has been
super supportive to all of these people
and obviously there are great mlops
framework and we're super happy to use
them so I want to thank them a lot I
want to tell you about this course they
have it's entirely free course so if you
go to 1db.courses dot courses is the top
level domain their courses are on
effective ml Ops and this first one is
on model development so this this is a
course as I said it's completely free
it's not cohort based so you can just go
through it at your own pace here you can
see a little bit of the curriculum so it
starts off with building a prototype
building a baseline evaluating your
model and going further than that so
you're not gonna build the like latest
and greatest large language model this
is really taking you from building a
model and then the steps how do I assess
the quality of the model how do I see
even whether I can you know make it
better how do I treat data how do I make
things reproducible for that you're
gonna train initially a unit with a
resnet baseline so all the code is
available right here and it's all really
nice so this is in fast Ai and it's
really about this process so about how
do I know where I stand with my model
and how do I know whether or not I
improve and if I improve how do I know
what it was due to how do I know the
causes like which of the things that I
turn made it better and how can I make
it even more better is that a thing even
more better even better and along the
way you'll also obviously learn how to
use weights and biases as an mlop system
which is amazing because weights and
biases is the greatest mlop system in
existence obviously and it's free
forever for personal use and for
academics and for open source teams like
ours very thankful again you should
absolutely check it out it's a great way
to get started into a more principled
approach into training and improving
models than just hammering things left
and right so if you've never worked with
weights and biases this is a great
opportunity to get into it if you are at
the beginning of your machine learning
career and want to get into coding this
is also a great way to get into it and
if you just want to see kind of what the
normal steps in a data science and
machine learning engineering workflow
are this is also an absolutely great
place the course has several modules and
builds upon itself it's guided through
as I said with Live code examples with
videos that explain everything to you
all the code is available and as I
already said it's free so it's 1db dot
courses go there check it out and I'll
see you around
[Music]
foreign
there's a new paper called Data
portraits and it proposes a both kind of
a framework but also a suggestion of how
to do what they call a data portrait a
data portrait is a thing like a little
little algorithm together with data that
allow you to do data membership checks
so the idea is that you know you train a
model on a big piece of data or you
receive a model that's trained on a big
piece of data and you wonder is this
piece of text that you have right here
was that used to train the model now
obviously it's very inconvenient to ship
around all of the data whatever
terabytes of data that these models are
trained on that's not really useful and
also a membership check through
terabytes of data would take a long time
right just going through them and
grapping your string likewise if you
were to ship something like a leucine
index that would be not super helpful
because it would also be quite big
compared to the data that it was trained
on so the authors here polls and
implementation based on Bloom filters
which essentially they say it amounts to
about three percent of the original data
so if you train a model on the pile with
three percent size of the original data
you could ship a piece of code and data
that allows anyone that receives the
model to also check whether a particular
string was in the data set that was used
to train nothing else right it's
essentially just a hash chat you provide
a string and it tells you yes this
string is in fact in the data set or not
I think it's a pretty cool idea maybe
this can be even improved a little bit
but it's certainly quite useful because
very often you wonder whether what
you're doing or not is actually in the
data set the method they propose here is
an approximation but because they
approximate they can get to such small
sizes the paper is called Data portraits
recording Foundation model training data
and the initial portrait so far there is
just one of the pile is available at
dataportraits.org
The Meta AI research releases data to
vac 2.0 a highly efficient
self-supervised learning or Vision
speech and text this is built up on data
to vac which they've released I believe
last year this is essentially just an
algorithm a generalized algorithm that
extends to speech to text and to images
and does self-supervised learning in
order to obtain good representations so
it's not the best algorithm it's not the
state of the art in any of these tasks
but it is a general algorithm that you
can apply to as I said a wide range of
modalities wide range of different
niches inside these modalities and you
get reasonable representations for that
data the algorithm is available in the
fair SEC package and it's basically
based on the fact that you mask out
piece of the input and from the rest you
try to predict that piece so it's the
age-old mask language modeling or masked
autoencoding or denoising autoencoding
idea however you want to call it
hugging face introduces gated models to
their Hub so this is a feature that
allows you as an uploader of a model to
specify that users will have to do
something before they can download that
model so you may ask a question to users
you may need to share some information
you may need to click a check box that
you agree to some terms of use so all of
this you can Define in your model card
and then hugging face will essentially
make sure to present that to users
before they're allowed to download your
model even via the API so they need to
essentially agree to that first you can
also specify manual approval which means
that users can only make a request to
you to download the model and then you
can go through the list and you can
decide who gets to download and who
doesn't get to download maybe based on
the answers they've given you to the to
the questionnaire the model uploaders
will have access to all that data that
you provide so be aware of that if you
ever fill out one of these forms now I
know I've ranted a bit much in recent
time so I want to keep this short but it
just reminds me of the prequels and
Amidala sayings so this is how Liberty
dies with thunderous Applause various
people welcome the addition of this very
much and I don't I think this is another
step into a world of non-open source
specifically if you put usage
restrictions on your code or your models
that is by definition not compatible
with the interpretation of Open Source
by for example gnu or the open source
foundation and I quite dislike hugging
face supporting this and and making that
easy now you can always say well these
people they would do it anyway they
would have to implement it otherwise
well okay but then let them let them
implement it a hugging faces Charter
says we open source AI by providing
One-Stop shop of resources ranging from
Models data sets ml demos and libraries
and this is clearly a step away from
that so I don't like like it but you now
have this ability if you want to also
from hoggingface hoggingface.js is a
JavaScript library that allows you to
interact with the Hub you know call the
inference API of hugging face if you
build some next.js application or so you
can interact with the hugging face API
using these libraries Microsoft releases
visual chat GPT now this is a paper
called talking drawing and editing with
visual Foundation models it uses chat
GPT to interact with a bunch of other
systems they open source the code right
here and you can see what it does is it
essentially Imports a whole bunch of
things so it Imports like blip it
Imports up sampling it Imports stable
diffusion it Imports control net and a
whole bunch of these things and then it
defines prompts and prefixes where you
can now interact with these things in a
chat manner so what does that mean they
have a bit of a demo right here so here
it says could you generate a cat for me
and then it I guess it calls stable
diffusion could you replace the cat with
a dog and remove the book so not exactly
sure what it could you generate the
canny edge of this image you can see
with using chat using dialogue you can
now interact with images so here there's
also visual question answering what
color is the motorcycle could you remove
the motorcycle from the image and so on
is very cool here the component is
called prompt manager so we're moving
more and more into this direction where
next to the software engineer and the ml
engineer there is now the prompt
engineer I think the field has been
predicting this for a while and it is
strange to really see this becoming a
reality to have you know serious work go
into okay what sentences can we put into
these models to make them do the things
we want it's weird but it's also quite
cool so this is open source have a look
have a try on the same note Microsoft
says Bing has crossed 100 million daily
active users is what Engadget writes
they say you know we're still a small
low single digit share play player
apparently that's a quote that's what
monopolies say if they don't want to be
called monopolies but being now sees an
influx because they've now activated
chat GPT on their search engine so they
retrieve websites and then they let chat
gbt answer some question for you or
summarize it or whatnot and that's quite
a new take and the cool way to use a
search engine doesn't always work but I
welcome the the change I welcome the
Paradigm Shift let's say now they also
say over a third of their users I think
over a third of their users is new users
every day you can get that ratio up in
two ways so for one you can acquire lots
of new users which I'm sure is the case
right here but also you can have users
come try it once and then never try it
again that's also how you get to a high
ratio of new daily users maybe it's a
little bit of a mix of both but if you
haven't tried sort of the new Bing yet
give it a try it's a different
experience certainly to searching the
internet classically and no Bing is not
paying me to say that
meta AI is introducing a new data set
called casual conversations V2 this is a
data set of people holding monologues
the monologues are either like a script
that they're given or they answer one of
five predefined questions but in a way
whichever they want they also get to
Define some attributes about themselves
and also they have professionals So Meta
has professional raters that who
determine other attributes in a as
objective a manner as possible so that
results in a data set of I think a
couple of thousand yes the data set
features 26 467 video monologues
featuring
5567 paid participants who voluntarily
took place in the collection of this
data set so if you're looking to
evaluate some algorithm and you want to
see it across different languages
different regions of the world different
types and kinds of people this might be
a good data set to consider
[Music]
anthropic released a blog post called
core views on AI safety when why what
and how they have all the question words
in the title this must be a good post
they Define how they see AI safety and
what they want to do going forward the
conclusion of this is what they call a
portfolio approach so here they say
taking a portfolio approach to AI safety
and what they essentially say is that we
don't exactly know yet how AI or future
AI more powerful AI is going to turn out
their optimistic scenarios where
everything is you know super helpful
super good there's intermediate
scenarios and then there's pessimistic
scenarios where AI systems are maybe not
as safe as we now think they are or not
as nice or people are using them to do
not nice things so we don't exactly know
yet which of these scenarios will happen
or predominantly happen so anthropic
says our best bet is to do research
essentially in a wide array of regions
try to balance our research and be sort
of prepared for all of these things
until we learn more I'm not really sure
what to take out of this like I'm not
really sure what information is
transmitted to me here through this blog
post essentially says that you know
we're not going to commit to any sort of
strong Direction right now but maybe I
also haven't read it correctly or maybe
haven't understood it that's obviously
possible maybe this is actually an AI
test I don't know in any case it's a
fairly long fairly detailed blog post
and if you're interested in anthropics
views on AI and AI safety give this a
read
there's considerably decent progress in
the fields that use AI in order to do
things in order to do mathematical
things Magnus Hummer is a Transformer
based approach to premised selection so
in this case you have some sort of
mathematical proof that you want to do
and the question is in in each proof
step what kind of premises do you select
to do that proofs that Magnus Hummer
replaces previous state-of-the-art
systems by a learned Transformer so
previous systems were very cleverly
engineered as far as I understand the
previous system is called sledgehammer
and now Magnus Hammer is a lot better
than Sledgehammer because Magnus Hammer
obviously uses very big transformers who
could have guessed on the right hand
side here you see the basic architecture
of Magnus hammer and the yellow thing
right here is a Transformer it's in fact
the same Transformer the same
Transformer backbone for different parts
of the pipeline and besides the fact
that it's very cool that even something
like math is making consider durable
progress using big deep learning models
I also think this area is just very cool
but just naming things so Magnus Hammer
replaces Sledgehammer which works in
conjunction with Isabel and it replaces
it in a system called Thor Thor being
the the bigger proof system that these
things are part of and by doing that it
you know improves the proof rate from 57
to 71 which I don't know if that's good
it seems a lot so good job and we're not
done with naming Baldur is a whole proof
generation and repair with large
language models so other than having a
step-by-step process and doing premise
selection this system tries to generate
entire proofs at once or and or repair
them which means that if you have a
broken proof like I proved it doesn't
quite work you want to revise and repair
it this also uses the old familiar
Isabel but as I said it tries to create
a proof in a more holistic way so it
creates the whole proof I have very
little idea of what's going on in these
fields but if this is of any interest to
you give these papers a read and also
the next paper deep symbolic regression
for physics Guided by unit constraints
so this is similar but it tries to
discover physical laws just from data
and the recognition here is this was
previously people have done this
essentially it's a search through
formulas until you can hit the correct
formula to fit the data but in this case
they also use units they say wait a
minute if we want to determine the
formula for the speed of something you
know the units must add up and cancel
out such that at the end there is a unit
for speed and by that as you can see in
this example right here they reduce the
search space of possible equations
drastically and by doing that they can
also drastically increase the number of
recovered physical laws that they can
tackle with these types of systems so
very cool give the paper a read in case
you're interested
the leakage of llama weights which we
discussed last week continues to be
hilarious news articles are being
written about it that llama is out of
the back should we expect a tidal wave
of disinformation oh no oh no this
information ah it's journalists but
apart from leaking we can actually go
the correct route right here so Andreas
keff has opened a pull request on the
Llama repository and this pull request
would change the license from this
non-commercial license this is the model
weight license not the code license two
Apache 2.0 so this would make the model
actually fully open source if this pull
request were to be merged the
argumentation is quite straightforward
it says first of all you claim to be
open but you're not so you bask in all
the glory of Open Source but then in
fact you're not open source and second
you essentially ask someone else to
re-spend the whole CO2 and the whole
compute that you have already spent to
generate this model pointlessly because
all the computations have already been
done so this is literally just
generating heat and CO2 if you agree
with this give this pull request a
thumbs up give it a little rocket to let
meta know that yes we agree with this
obviously this gonna be Optima but I
would welcome if you work at matuck
maybe you can bump someone internally
this would help the open source
Community quite a lot and would raise
the image of meta in the eyes of the
community I think
speaking of licenses and terms there is
a data set called self-instruct so this
is an instruction tuning data set which
have become popular recently with chat
GPT this is an instruction tuning data
set that has been generated using the
open AI API while this is very cool
there is a problem namely the open AI
terms of service state that it is
forbidden to use the services to develop
Foundation models or other large-scale
models that compete with open AI let's
say you take this data set and you train
it and upload the model on the hugging
face Hub technically that could be seen
as a you know you produce a model that
competes with open AI even if you do it
for your own company then you use your
model instead of going to the open AI
API or even worse you offer other people
to use your model all of that could be
construed as being not in agreement with
the open AI terms of service now just
this data set existing doesn't violate
the terms yet but training on this data
set May so it's going to be interesting
to see what happens once people start
training models from this data set it's
going to be interesting to see if a
hugging face actually does keep this
data set up because the data set pretty
explicitly sort of is on the way to
violating open AI terms of service my
opinion again not a lawyer uh you know
no legal advice I think it's going to be
interesting to see it's going to set a
precedent that presidents will decide
over the foreseeable future
robotics at Google Tu Berlin and Google
research release palm e and embodied
multimodal language model this is a
giant language model it's one of these
Pathways model by Google where not
always all the network is active and
therefore they can go to many more
parameters so this is a multi-modal
model it can input text it can input
images the way it does that as you can
see right here is it takes the images
and it puts their embedding tokens
essentially as tokens and after the
embedding layer so you can mix text
tokens by using the text embedding layer
with something like image tokens by
using a vid like a vision Transformer
and then taking the representation
tokens and putting them inside the text
token so it's all just tokens it's all
just token embedding you can even do
that with more stuff like with the
instructions with trajectories with
positions with all kinds of things you
just map it to an embedding space of
tokens you can use it with a large
language model and that's what this
paper does right here and it uses it to
empower their robots to do various
different tasks for example bring me the
rice chips from the drawer this robot
obviously knows how to grasp stuff and
stone but has not been exposed to these
particular objects and you could see a
human don't do this if these robots end
up becoming like super powerful this
human you're you're you're on the list
oh oh please be nice to the robot these
robots they look familiar I think in
last week's Story We announced that that
division was decommissioned so I guess
the robots found a new home which is
good in any case we don't know too much
more about this palm e because obviously
Google doesn't really let anyone use
their models but their demos seem quite
convincing so you can give the robot
instructions right here push the Red
Blocks to the coffee cup it struggles
but after a while it sort of it gets
there yeah come on come on come on good
job good job you can use this model in
various different ways but again there
is a paper there is this bit of a demo
there's not yet a model
also Google research releases USM a
speech model for 100 plus languages
they've recently announced their 1 000
languages initiative and in this model
they have 300 languages as far as as I
can tell over 300 languages to do speech
recognition so this they can achieve
because they pre-train in an
unsupervised Fashion on very large data
set who would have thought and then they
realized once they fine-tune on where
they actually have data let's say a
pre-trained on just recordings of lots
and lots of voice samples and then you
fine-tune actually on you know doing the
speech recognition doing the
transcription and so on if you have task
specific paired data where you have the
speech and you have the actual
transcription you can train on that and
they realize that that has big
generalization power and makes
especially the languages that aren't as
frequent it makes performance on those
languages quite a lot bigger so by
training a lot more or on sort of the
languages where you have a lot of
training data like labeled data because
of the pre-training it this generalizes
to the languages where you don't have a
lot of data so this is a cool method to
sort of expand the abilities of these
models even to kinds of data that you
don't see that often so this model for
example beats the open AI whisper model
in speech transcription and it also
beats the YouTube internal caption
Generation by a tiny bit but it does so
given that this is Google we may soon
have better subtitles in YouTube now
again not much of of source code or
anything but researchers can request
access to the USM API and the last model
for today gilgan is open set grounded
text to image generation so this is text
to image generation and it's based on on
this model here glip which is grounded
language image pre-training by grounding
these people mean that for example if
you have some bounding boxes around the
objects that you want to place in an
image you give a caption in this one
Elon Musk and Emma Watson on a movie
poster but you also specify the
positions of Elon Musk and Emma Watson
and the generation is supposed to adhere
to those things on top of that you can
also you know give some style image
which they also consider to be grounding
so grounding is when you have extra
information that grounds the generation
of an image rather than just providing a
text description and then letting it do
whatever so you can do that you can
input poses as you can see right here
you can have these grounding images
where you essentially take the objects
from for example this backpack right
here you can place it on a piece of
grass this opens up a lot of cool new
possibilities and there is a demo so in
the demo I produced a dog and a turtle
at a rave partying it up crazy fish
i-90s I place the dog and the turtle and
I think I think that turned out pretty
well yeah look at that the project page
here is also quite thorough in
explaining what's happening in this
paper for example they do freeze most of
the pre-trained models and then sort of
add this conditioning this grounding
information using in between layers that
they train while keeping the others
Frozen look at that Walter White in GTA
5 so you can place Walter you can place
a car in the boat so you can place stuff
that is not in the in the text caption
right here so you can just Place random
stuff like a bulldog here two pirate
chips in the ocean of Minecraft very
very cool also opens up again a lot of
possibilities and you can see right here
especially in sort of what they call
spatially counter factual generations
for example a hen is hatching a huge egg
or an apple and a same-sized dog like
more classical models like stable
diffusion where you don't have this
grounding they struggle with it here
that the dog isn't isn't necessarily the
same size enough as an Apple so it is
weirdly small at least whatever isn't
the head and here the the hen doesn't
really like a huge egg but like a huge
amount of eggs and you can see with the
grounding this just becomes a a lot
easier for the model to really assess
what it's supposed to be doing and
lastly the first ever complete map of an
insect brain has been released this is
called a connectome so this is a map
that fully shows what neurons exist in
in this animal and how they are
connected so every single connection
between two neurons is represented in
this Atlas right here this has been done
before for like round worms but this
connectome right here I think is an
order of magnitude larger in the amount
of neurons than previous connectomes and
obviously with more neurons the number
of connections increase by even more so
this is pretty cool so yeah if you are
interested in this type of research this
is a very cool contribution to the world
of science and again helps us understand
ourselves from a bit of a different
direction than AI but still very good
alright that was it for ML news thank
you so much for being here I'll see you
around next week
[Music]
foreign